[Musique]
le rôle de la médecine de ville
c'est de pouvoir dans un premier temps
on recevoir les gens qui le demande qui
sont suspect de covile c'est à dire
qu'ils ont quelques symptômes pouvant
évoquer un co vide et pour éviter de
faire croiser des populations au sein
des cabinets on leur dit d'aller en
préférence dans ces centres dédiés par
régulation par le 15 et par leur médecin
traitant
c'est à dire que vous appelez la
population appelle son médecin traitant
lui d'éclipsé décrit ses symptômes et le
médecin traitant dit bah oui je peux
vous recevoir parce que je pense qu'il
n'ya aucun souci ou non je préfère pas
vous recevoir
je préfère vous adresser à ces centres
dédiés où on vous examinera et on fera
un diagnostic et en fonction de ça je
vous serez pris en charge
on a commencé par d un centre dédié à
l'hôpital mignot y en a un qui s'est
ouvert sur l'hôpital de saint germain
mais c'est des locaux isolé par rapport
au reste de l'hôpital généralement et
puis par exemple à poissy ça n'a rien à
voir avec l'hôpital même si c'est un 150
m là c'est le maire qui a offert le
gymnase qui l'a équipé qu'il a organisée
avec les médecins de poissy et la
consultation se fera à ce niveau là
[Musique]
on a eu un message un peu complexes de
notre premier ministre qui nous a dit
vous ne pouvez plus allez consulter
votre médecin et je crois que ça c'est
pas possible il ya d'autres pathologies
qui doivent avoir une prise en charge
par la médecine de ville
donc pour sécuriser les circuits on
oriente plutôt les médecins
potentiellement covic positif vers des
centres dédiés comme sa plus grande
sécurité
les autres balades pour d'autres
pathologies peuvent aller dans les
cabinets médicaux
on a cinq qui sont vraiment
opérationnels et puis d'autres qui sont
le but c'est de couvrir tout le
territoire du département 78 je crois
que pour ça on a fait avec grâce avec
l'action de la rs des milieux
hospitaliers où on a une coordination
parfaite
on est en train d'organiser l'ensemble
du territoire du soixante dix huit pour
pouvoir répondre à toute la population
[Musique]
je vais prendre l'exemple de millions
qui a été un des premiers centres
ouverts avec le trille l on a ouvert
l'agenda le dimanche dans la journée le
lundi il y avait déjà 15 de
consultations de patients le mardi
c'était plein et donc on va s'adapter
c'est à dire que pour l'instant on met
simplement un médecin par toutes les
trois heures mais s'il ya besoin on est
en capacité de doubler les effectifs ou
même de les tripler au cas où